that reeves as the batman offers up a
major character reveal during the film's
final moments and this is your last
spoiler warning before we get into it
what if we told you there was supposed
to be an even bigger more pivotal scene
at arkham asylum much earlier in the
movie involving the surprise prisoner
that got cut as reeves put it while
speaking to ign
the movie is not an origin tale for
batman but it's his early days it really
is an origin tale for the rogues
galleries
not only is this origin tale sentiment
applicable to the character we meet in
the third act but it also applies to the
other antagonists we made earlier in the
movie over the course of the nearly
three hour run time the batman boasts
moviegoers are introduced to the riddler
penguin and the catwoman followed by the
widely talked about arkham reveal of
joker played by barry kyogen in reeves
batman universe the character is
currently locked up for some unknown
reason and as the director tells ign is
only in his early infancy as the clown
prince of crime in fact the big reveal
fans get at the end of the batman was
actually supposed to be a companion
scene to a much bigger breakout moment
involving the character at arkham asylum
that would have occurred earlier in the
movie the scene would have featured
robert pattinson's dark knight coming to
consult with the joker at arkham in an
attempt to profile the riddler in the
hopes of stopping him reeves told ign
the reason that joker's in the movie is
there was actually another scene that
was earlier the scene that was not in
the movie a scene that this is really
the companion to it's a scene where
batman is so unnerved because the
riddler is writing to him and he figures
he's got to profile this killer so he
goes to see another killer that he's
clearly had an experience with in these
first two years and this killer in the
story is not yet the character that we
come to know as reeves describes it dc
villains will often declare their alter
egos in response to batman's existence
and arrival and gotham throughout the
comics so this is a direction that he
wanted to go in too we have a joker
that's not yet the joker as for why the
scene involving batman and joker was cut
the filmmaker did not say but he did
reveal what warner brothers has planned
for in the future reeves insisted during
his interview with ign that fans will
get to see his deleted joker and batman
scene at some point in the future
whether the scene will appear in a
director's cut like zack snyder's
justice league or perhaps a blu-ray dvd
feature of some sort remains to be seen
the scene will release at some point in
the scene that you'll see in the future
you'll see that we worked on what he'd
look like and he's kind of held in this
kind of very suspenseful way away from
you visually as for what's next for the
iconic dc baddie should he pop up again
in the future as anybody's guess but one
thing we know for sure is that reeves
has big plans for him telling ign he's
eventually going to declare himself as a
clown declare himself as the joker
youtube users who watched the interview
and heard this declaration were excited
to learn that reeves was taking things
slow but serious with the character
especially since it gave paul danos
riddler more time to shine in the batman
one user wrote i'm actually glad they
cut the scene because if they showed him
in the middle of the movie people would
just think about joker and ignore paul
dano's excellent riddler performance
another commenter noted how excited they
were to see a future joker after
enjoying the look of another member of
batman's rogues gallery that popped up
in the batman keeping him in the shadows
gives him more time to work on his look
which is being designed by the same
people who did the penguin
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]